if i'm going to talk about the most
iconic moment
in christopher eccleston's time on
doctor who
the scene that rises above all others
well
there really is only one that sprang to
mind just this once
everybody but hold on let's talk about
why this is so amazing
[Music]
hi there now i know my regular viewers
were expecting the latest installment of
take two doctor who reviews today but
instead
i have something special for you don't
worry i will get to in the forest of the
night i
oh i'll get to it
but uh if you are into nerdy pop culture
channels then you might have caught the
one excellent scene semi-collaboration
thing that happened earlier this year
where a bunch of geeky pop culture
channels talked about their favorite
scenes
from the x-men movies well with the
announcement of christopher eccleston
returning to the role of the ninth
doctor
next year via big finish audio dramas
shebogan who decided to organize as
many youtubers as possible to talk about
our favorite ninth doctor scenes and
i'm not lying when i say i really only
had one pick
it's the climactic scene from
eccleston's 10th episode
the doctor dances the doctor dances
is the second half of a two-parter which
i'd argue
between the two of them is the best
story of
series one the two-parter written by
future showrunner stephen moffat has
everything humor great guest stars
creeping terror a barely understood
threat
i could honestly go on for two hours on
these episodes and the only reason i'm
not going to do that is because we're
here to focus on
one fantastic scene and it is the scene
that the entire story
possibly the entire revived show up to
this point
has been building two the doctrine rose
along with nancy and the newly
introduced captain jack harkness
have been trying to figure out what is
going on with a gas mask wearing child
calling for his mother in the middle of
bombed out
london during the blitz physical contact
with the child
has caused others to grow gas masks on
their face
and they are all asking the same
question
with the condition having gone airborne
the team has rushed to a supposedly
empty alien medical capsule and realized
that escaped microscopic medical
machines called nana jeans
are the cause of all the trouble captain
jack teleports out
the doctor pushes young nancy who's been
claiming to be the child's sister since
the beginning of the story
to answer that repeated question
truthfully nancy has been hiding from
the truth
her entire life the truth that
jamie the boy who became the empty child
isn't
her brother but her son
this is all done well slowly built up
the work by florence hoath
as nancy is spot on capturing the pain
of having to say
the truth that she has been running from
and the shame
of having hidden it from even her
own child and then comes the first
glimpse of what this truly means
for the ninth doctor
come on please this is where the facade
of confidence that the doctor just used
to get nancy to reach out
drops away and we get to see how truly
desperate he is yeah
he had a plan but he didn't know it
would work this
line delivery makes it clear that he is
more than prepared to
plead in the hope that maybe
just maybe this will work
as the microscopic nanogenes recognize
the parent dna
they come to realize how they have been
misunderstanding what humans are
supposed to be
even as the whole thing looks like it's
worked
the doctor still can't quite bring
himself to have full confidence in that
and he pleads one more time
oh come on give me a day like this
give me this one this line from
eccleston
isn't about winning this day it's about
every day
where he didn't win every day where
people
died and he couldn't stop it and the joy
on his face when he lifts that gas mask
from jamie's head the rapturous
joy at realizing that it's worked is
palpable and we are not done yet
jack returns to stop a bomb from
dropping on the site the doctor
sets up to spread the nana genes
once the disease now the cure
this is actually pretty big because
there really was
no giveaway prior to this that the
condition
was going to be reversible contrast that
was something like
the idiot's lantern where rose suffers a
fate that has already been met by
numerous people and we automatically
know that it's going to be reversed
because it's happened to a companion of
course they're going to undo it
but that's not the case here it is
completely possible that
all the people who've been changed won't
return to normal we can
trust that they'll be stopped and the
threat will be resolved but we can't be
sure that they'll actually be
saved but they are
this small army of gas masks zombies
are restored to once they once were and
we
get everybody lives
just this once everybody lives
that's not just a good line if you
consider two parters to be a single
story
then this is the eighth story of series
one and every
other one prior to this has seen people
die from clive to jabe gwyneth
multiple members of unit dozens of
security guards pete
and more and there is yet to be a story
without a casualty
and while we won't learn full details
for some time
we do know already that the doctor is
starting this series coming off of the
time war where he believes
himself to be the only survivor of his
home planet and his species
he's been seeing death every day and we
don't even
know for how long but finally
after all that he gets a day
where everybody lives and this sentiment
extends
way beyond the victims the bad guys turn
out to be a medical device that didn't
know it was making a mistake
there's no monster no actual villain
which means that
everybody lives means truly everybody
not every human but the invading aliens
are dead
there's no body count not even a fallen
foe
everybody absolutely everybody
lives and that's what the episode has
been building to
so what the episode before it was
building to it is what the entire series
up to this point has been building to
giving the doctor one truly glorious day
where nobody's sacrificed
nobody's abandoned nobody falls and
everybody lives this scene
is great in isolation but the weight of
what the show has given us up to that
point
along with what is clearly a deeply
painful background for the doctor
oh that puts it over the top without
that is the foundation
the scene wouldn't hit the way it does
i've loved this from the very first time
i saw it
but it has actually become more
meaningful to me
since i had the privilege of getting to
see and meet
christopher eccleston at gallifrey one
earlier this year before
everything got locked down one of the
things he was open about
was that his background as an actor
prior to doctor who was very
heavy serious dour material
and he was frequently uneasy when he was
called him on to be
happy or funny or joyous
that was kind of amazing to me because
his joyful moments were what hooked me
into his version of the doctor right
from the first episode
and there was no moment more joyful than
this
and i am delighted to say that i had the
chance to tell him that
when he signed the photo that i had
taken with him
we all have things
that we are uncomfortable doing or
showing
the world and for me at least there are
a few things more
reassuring than being told that the
thing that i worried about sharing
helped people connect with me
this scene gets absolutely everything
right the emotion the uplifting music a
perfectly pitched performance from
eccleston it all
comes together to make one fantastic
scene
thank you for watching i have a patreon
that supports me
and this channel please leave your
comments below share this video around
and
be sure to check out other videos in
this collaborative project
there are a ton of great creators in on
this
and maybe you'll even discover some new
ones they have picked
some really stellar scenes to cover and
i want you to please
remember through all this be well
be safe and be kind
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]